comme beaucoup de parents facile c'est
un film qu'on a mis en place ce lien est
à regarder on l'a retrouvé ce matin
c'est un rempli de pétrole hier il était
vers un oui oui hier ils étaient bien ce
qu'on peut voir sur la plage
cette plage ils l'ont pourtant nettoyer
hier mais aujourd'hui tout est déjà
refaire difficile à admettre pour ces
hommes de la sécurité civile qui en sont
à leur quatrième séjour ici ça fait un
an qu'on vient un jour bonjour on est
des gens même quoi pression car on sait
pas
endroit un peu décourageant pour ça
ainsi va la dépollution des plages au
gré des marées des tempêtes qui ramène
périodiquement des plaques de fioul
trente deux chantiers sont encore en
cours pourtant il faut le dire le
répéter
95% des plages de loire-atlantique sont
propres la reconquête aura pris une
année et coûté 400 millions de francs
rien qu'à l'état elle aura aussi permis
de prendre conscience de l'importance de
ce patrimoine qui ne s'entretient pas
tout seul marée noire ou pas on oublie
que c'est notre or blanc et la marée
noire nous a bien montré que 1
le touriste qu'il fallait aller le
chercher aujourd'hui pour générer les
emplois qui y sont liés puis deux
il fallait qu'on travaille des plages et
la décision qui a été prise par exemple
à pornichet c'est que contrairement aux
autres années
dès le mois d'avril on va chercher à
mettre les plages en très bon état
n'exagérons rien quand même la marée
noire n'a rien d'une bonne affaire pour
les communes sinistrées
mesquer 1300 habitants a dépensé près
d'un million de francs en un an
autant d'argent en moins pour d'autres
priorités le fleurissement des communes
vous y avait des tas de choses comme ça
qui sont importantes et qu'on a un petit
peu laissé à l'abandon
c'est certain cependant m sans parler du
personnel qui est utilisé uniquement
pour nettoyer et s'occuper déclare
madame le maire sait de quoi elle parle
elle vient de perdre un procès contre
total à qui elle réclamait le
remboursement de ses dépenses
le littoral est aujourd'hui à peu près
propre désormais le combat s'est déplacé
de la plage au prétoire